-Welcome back! We have such
a great show for you tonight.
And you know what?
Before we go, I'm just --
I'm a little hungry.
If you don't mind,
I just want to grab something
from the "Tonight Show" freezer
real quick.
It'll take a second.
It just -- I'm so sorry
about this. I'm sorry.
Thank you guys so much.
I appreciate it.
♪♪
-♪ Freezer Secrets ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh! No, no!
No, no, no! I'm --
Help, help! I'm --
Help, I'm stuck in the freezer!
I'm stuck in the freezer.
Oh, gosh, I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's no use.
-Fred Armisen?
What are you doing in here?
-I thought this was
the dressing room.
and I just left the window open.
-This is awful.
I knew it was a mistake
buying a soundproof freezer.
[ Laughter ]
I knew -- I knew it.
We're doomed.
-Well, since this is the end,
I guess I have a few secrets
I need to get off my chest.
-Same.
-All right.
You know that new Harry Styles
song, "Watermelon Sugar?"
-Of course. Yeah, I listen
to it every day. It's new.
-Well, it took me...
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Brand new. It took me
an embarrassing amount of time
to realize that the song
is actually a double entendre.
-Right, right, right. And --
-It's about diabetes.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-One time I saw Yoplait yogurt
in the fridge with my coworker
Bethany's name on it.
I took it anyway and ate it.
-Oh, yeah. I did something
similar once.
-Really?
-Yeah.
I caused
the 2008 financial crisis.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not similar at all.
I mean, that --
And how did you do that?
-I don't know.
I had a day off and I was bored.
-In the '90, I had a bitter feud
with the Taco Bell Chihuahua.
-I get it, but why?
-We auditioned
for the same part.
We are the final two
in the running
to be Taco Bell's
new spokeschihuahua.
He beat me out because
I was six feet tall and a human.
-Have you talked to him since?
-Nah, nah, nah.
Once he had that gordita money,
he became a real monster.
-I have one.
I used to work
as a part-time exorcist,
but I got fired
because I was too polite
with the demonic entities.
I'd say the power of Christ
would prefer
you get out of here.
The power of Christ
is going to count to three.
One, two, two and a half...
-Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've lied about my age,
my whole career.
I'm actually 96.
You know those prosthetics
that Johnny Knoxville wears
in "Bad Grandpa?"
-Oh, yeah.
Amazing prosthetics.
-Yeah, well,
he let me borrow them,
and I wear them inside out
to make me look younger.
-I have a secret family.
-Fred, you're not married.
I think you need to be married
with kids in order
to have a second family
that's a secret.
-Oh, okay. In that case,
I just have a regular family
that I don't like.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-You know how I have that side
job as a valet in Vatican City?
-Of course, everyone knows
that about you.
-Yeah, but, well, sometimes --
sometimes at night, I --
I take the Popemobile.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Sometimes -- Sometimes at night.
-Yeah.
I... [ Laughs ]
I-I take the Popemobile out --
[ Laughs ]
I take the Popemobile out
for a joyride.
-No, that's --
That's fine. Live a little.
-Yeah. Yeah. Well, well, well.
The Pope has
a limited edition
"Minions: The Rise of Gru"
Big Gulp cup
and I drank out of it.
-I never graduated
from high school.
-Well, that's nothing
to be ashamed of.
-Because I accidentally
killed my principal.
-W-What?
-As he was handing me
my diploma, I threw my cap up
in the air too early,
and one of those sharp points
hit him right this angle,
and it sliced him
completely in half.
-Oh, my God.
How is that possible?
-My hat was made of metal.
It was my final project
for shop class.
I got a "B."
-You know, M&M's old slogan,
"Melts in your mouth,
not in your hands?"
-Yeah?
-I have a rare medical condition
where M&Ms melt in my hands
and not in my mouth.
-I don't actually need
to wear glasses.
I only wear them
so people think I'm cool.
-I'm in the same boat.
I actually don't have eyeballs.
I stole these from
a Build-A-Bear workshop.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. I guess I never noticed.
You have such beady, dead eyes.
-Thank you.
I mean, I shouldn't thank you.
I should thank Build-A-Bear.
-I can't keep this
to myself anymore.
I'm having a non-sexual,
non-romantic affair
with my dentist, Dr. Jimenez.
He just cleans my teeth,
I exchange insurance info
with the front desk person,
and then I leave.
-I don't think that's an affair.
-Oh, yeah?
Then how do you explain
the steamy voicemail he left me?
-Hi, Fred.
This is Amanda calling
from Dr. Jimenez's office.
You have a tooth
cleaning scheduled
for June 20th at 9 a.m..
-Wow, he is in love with you,
-Fred? Jimmy?
-What? Higgins!
We're saved!
-What are you guys doing
in the men's room?
-This isn't the men's room.
It's a freezer.
-Oh, nobody told me that.
Don't look in that corner.
[ Both shouting indistinctly ]
-Those aren't Baby Ruth bars.
-This has been
Freezer Secrets.
Stick around for more
"Tonight Show" after the break.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪